من على سطح احد المنازل يطلق جندي النار
نحو نقاط تمركز
داعش معركه تحرير هذه المدينه قد وصلت
لشهر السابع والمنهك بقتال في الشوارع
وبين
المنازل الجنود العراقيون وضعوا ثين
لمقاتلين من داعش فوق سيارتهم مثل تذكار
للصيد يلتقطون صوره السيلفي تخليدا
للمناسبه هذا ما اصبحت عليه خلافتهم بحسب
تعبيرهم التي اكدوا بقائها وتوسعها قنابل
البزوك المصنوعه محليا تملا الشوارع اذ
ادار داعش عشرات الورش في المناطق السكنيه
لصناعه هذه الاسلحه وغيرها نعمل كامل
تصنيع صواريخ ضد الدبابه صواريخ ضد الدرو
ضد المشار صوارخ قاذفه
لم يتبقى غير 10% من الموصل تحت سيطره
داعش لكن السيطره على هذه المنطقه الصغيره
لن يكون سهلا
ابدا المكان الذي يتصاعد منه الدخان هو حي
السابع عشر من تموز وهو الحي الاول الذي
دخله داعش في يوليو عام
2014 اعادوا تسميته بفتح احتفالا
بالفتوحات الاوليه للامبراطوريه الاسلاميه
القاده في الجيش هنا يقولون ان معركه
الساب عشر من تموز ستكون
الاصعب يتحدث المقدم ابو فاطمه على الهاتف
مع السكان داخل هذا الحي ماساويه الى ابعد
الحدود لا طعام لا يعني ارزاق لا مي قضايا
الطبابه يقول انهم ينتظرون فقط القوات
لتحريرهم بعضهم لم يتمكن من الانتظار
ليخطر بحياتهم من اجل الهرم احنا طلعنا
اليوم على باش وها بنتي بعل بالحمام زلمت
يخبر بنا يقول عمه اطلع اطلع اقول اخويا
ما نقدر يعني نطلع ما نقدر نطلع من
القصف سنا قلنا خلنا نتوكل على الله ونطلع
ابو سعيد لم يهرب من المنطقه المجاوره
للموصل اذ كان مختبئا مع عائلته اسفل درج
المنزل منتظرا دخول القوات العراقيه الان
يرشدهم الى منازل داعش المهجوره واحدا تلو
الاخر اراقبهم واحفظ اسمائهم يقول انه قد
جمع معلومات خلال اعوام الماضيه كان
يراقبهم ويكتب اسمائهم ويراقب افعالهم
والان يشارك كل شيء مع الضباط حسب تعبيره
كبار القاله الذين يتفحصون الاسلحه
المستولى عليها من داعش واثقون من تحقيق
الانتصار قبل نهايه شهر مايو سننتصر قبل
رمضان يقول رئيس اركان الجيش العراقي
عثمان الغانمي انهم سينتصرون بمشيئه الله
قبل شهر رمضان وسيعلن تحرير الموصل واهلها
من حثاله داعش القذره
هؤلاء الذين يصفهم بالحث القادره لم
يستسلموا بعد كما تظهر رصاصه القناص هذه
التي اخطات كامتنا
بانشد